for thousands of years the most common
building materials have been stone brick
and wood they've also been the most
charming aging beautifully and
suggesting a special kind of nobility
and strength
when modernist architecture was born in
the early 20th century traditional
materials quickly gave way to the three
quintessential modern ingredients
concrete steel and sheet glass
the result has in far too many cases
appeared brutal uncaring and alienating
the buildings have not aged very well
either
could modern architects not learn to
work with traditional materials while
retaining the forms and the spirit of
our own times
this is the question so beautifully
answered by one of the greatest of all
modernists the american architect louis
khan
khan was born in russia in 1901 and
emigrated with his parents to the u.s at
the age of three
as a young man he studied architecture
at the university of pennsylvania but
his career truly blossomed in the 1950s
after a trip to rome led him to a new
appreciation of the beauty of ancient
roman architecture
khan's major contribution to modern
architecture was to include ancient
elements in his work without losing the
innovation and clarity of modernism
he reminded the modernists that they
could be in dialogue with their most
illustrious predecessors
one symptom of the successful
rehabilitation of the old was khan's
affection for symmetry which many modern
architects had come to view as
authoritarian unimaginative and
conformist
khan designed the salk institute in la
jolla california as a complex of
buildings identical on either side of a
central fountain a symmetry
characteristic of what is known as the
bosar style
khan was unperturbed by this apparent
regression
if people want to see buzar it's fine
with me he said i'm as interested in
good architecture as anybody else
like a city planner for 19th century
paris or berlin khan used identical rows
of buildings to draw the viewer's eye to
the center of his design and out beyond
it the fountain that runs through the
center of the institute aligns with the
path of the sun on both the autumnal and
vernal equinox
khan used symmetry not as an aesthetic
default but with great intentionality to
provide one with a sense of balance
focus and momentum
khan also managed to create a feeling of
grandeur rarely seen in modern
architecture we might gape at the height
of a skyscraper but rarely does it evoke
the kind of ore that a great cathedral
can generate khan managed to reintroduce
a feeling of magnificence into modern
works in the yale center for british art
he draws the viewer's eyes upwards to
the high windowed ceiling much as though
it were the dome of a church even the
staircases create a sense of lofty space
and height
rather than resorting only to steel
concrete and glass khan regularly sought
out a wide variety of older and more
sensory materials he worked with the
best consultants to find new uses for
ceramic copper and especially brick
khan liked cleverly to juxtapose older
and newer materials like oak with
concrete we tend to associate oak with
tradition victorian smoking rooms or
solemn libraries while concrete reminds
us of impersonal factories and remote
futuristic buildings but put together
the two mediums demonstrate strikingly
different yet remarkably complementary
virtues the wood gives off a feeling of
warmth and domesticity while concrete
provides a sense of strength and
stability
the combination subtly promises a
reconciliation between the old and the
new between comfort and security
khan was drawn to the idea of making
buildings that would feel like monuments
at a time when most modern architects
firmly rejected monuments as
authoritarian and sentimental in 1938
the architectural critic lewis mumford
declared if it's a monument it's not
modern if it's modern it cannot be a
monument but khan rather liked the
feeling of authority and was confident
enough in his democratic credentials not
to mind borrowing from some of the moves
of more dictatorial regimes after his
important trip to rome he wrote i
finally realized that the architecture
of italy will remain as the
inspirational source of all works of the
future those who don't see it that way
ought to look again our stuff looks tiny
compared to it
his most substantial building was
perhaps the national assembly in dakar
bangladesh though recognizably modern it
also seems in some ways eternal in its
massiveness echoing to the memories of
the cathedrals the great mosques and
even the pyramids
many of khan's buildings feel luxurious
but this isn't the luxury of glitz or
gold of an oil-rich kingdom rather the
luxury of buildings that aspire to still
be around in 600 years time the luxury
of eternity the kimball art museum in
texas uses travertine marble white oak
and concrete arranged in 300 foot bays
each fronted by an open barrel vaulted
portico it's possibly the most beautiful
building in the world
when khan died in 1974 he was the most
famous architect in the united states
and he remains deeply influential to
this day his ultimate importance lay in
his ability to transcend dogmatic
modernism and return the best elements
of traditional architecture to their
rightful place in the canon he reminds
us that the real goal of buildings isn't
so much to shock dazzle or confuse as to
be the equals of the venerable buildings
we've long loved in the ancient world
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more